vmpd's sheriff's multicultural advisory
council
thank you all for joining us today
and as we've had a lot of conversation
particularly over these past few weeks
and months about racially motivated
incidents
particularly against members of the
asian community
there's a lot of diversity within the
aapi community but this has impacted a
lot of you in similar ways
would you be able to talk about the
impact you've seen on the aapi community
uh a.g tong
thank you teresa and i want to thank uh
general ford for hosting us here um
we came in as ags together and
after hearing general ford's bio it's
clear to me that
i'm just the asian aaron ford
on the east coast um and uh
i have a a lot of catching up to do to
general ford he's a great friend
a great partner a great partner on these
issues
and i just want everyone in nevada to
know that
you know as soon as this started
happening not just in the last couple of
weeks but
um you know over the last year or more
general ford has
really been very supportive of me and
the aapi community across the country
and i really want to thank him for that
um
and and it's great to be with so many
friends including my sister next door
congresswoman
grace mong um it's great to see her and
i can't wait till we can get together
in person all of us um
let me just say first of all i think
asian americans and pacific islanders
across the country
were scared we're scared because
it's really hard to wake up in the
morning and go outside and get in your
car
and to feel like you're being targeted
like you're being hunted and
today our country really has been
assaulted
by several images first is the image
of george floyd being murdered in
minnesota
and we're reliving that trauma again
today in this week
and and two more images two videos
coming out of new york unfortunately of
a young man being assaulted on a subway
violently knocked unconscious
and an asian-american woman being kicked
and beaten to the ground
and suffering very serious injuries and
this is something that all of us feel
personally
viscerally you know all people of color
all communities
people have been persecuted or in
marginalized or minority communities
this affects all of us doesn't matter if
you're
an attorney general or a congresswoman
or a small business person
like my parents it all of us feel
vulnerable
and i think for me um one of the hardest
things
was a that we're reliving the trauma
over and over again
of of not only being targeted but of
being invisible
you know people are surprised
that there's violence against asian
americans and pacific islanders exactly
i can't believe this is happening and
and my response is
why why can't you believe it this has
been happening
for for decades and and years and
hundreds of years
and and just to act surprised or to
profess
that this is surprising or something new
is to deny that the chinese exclusion
act happened
or that the pay jack happened or that
vincent chin
was beat death in detroit skin or
or that 125 000 japanese americans
were interned in camps on american soil
japanese american citizens many
out west uh near where many of the
nevadans are joining us tonight
on this uh virtual meeting so
you know for me as an asian american it
i just want to scream when
people are like wow this is incredible i
can't believe it's happening yes it's
happening it happens all the time
in our community and the only way it's
going to change
is if people reckon with that history
understand that history
understand that asian americans and
pacific islanders have been targeted
we've had a target on our backs for a
very long time
in this country and and for too long
we've been
invisible in the national conversation
about race
racism and hate and and now we get the
opportunity to really have that
conversation
uh thank you for that um i do want to
know we've been joined by attorney
general banta
um and i also want to note that you i
need to update your title it still says
assemblymember but thank you for joining
us
um i um going back to that question um
grace fergara mctell
hi i want to thank um aj ford for having
this conversation and everyone i'm
so humbled and grateful being in the
panel with such great
uh api leaders and our country
so but uh advocating for a bad community
has been a constant part of my life
professionally and personally and as a
filipino immigrant i have a
23 year old son ensuring that the future
generation
grow up in a country that can be proud
of is really important and new to my
heart
but i think all of us here on this panel
have witnessed first
hand the challenge of living in america
as aapi
i came here as an adult and i know what
it looks like and
like what aj tom says it's not new
it's been happening it's just because
we've been
invisible for a long time so my
observation
in our union and our community is a call
to action
last year in the midst of this pandemic
we witnessed a president
the demonized asian americans and we
sell outbursts of violence
and all communities of color across the
country
so our response to is to come together
we got to unite
right so sda you look at 1107 made a
commitment to
being an anti-racist organization we hit
the streets with our communities
within our own community we amplify
growing incidents of violence against
aapi
uh we're calling our leaders and
communities to take action
but i think this is something that uh
i'm
i'm very i'm glad that this conversation
is happening because it's been existing
for a long time
and no one is recognizing it it seems
like
the cry for help in the past is unheard
right no one no one listens because of
again
this invisibility of the api
and and being the modern minority
like uh it's it's
it's heartbreaking that we have to have
elderly that needs to be hurt we have
families that have to be hurt
to really start this conversation we
would we should have had this
conversation a long time ago
and um so i am grateful for our leaders
in this country like congresswoman may
a.g for tong aj ford a.g ford and a.g
tong to have this kind of conversation
and
um i'm really grateful to be part of it
but i think
we should continue having this
conversation and educate our
not only our children but we have to uh
educate our community my certainly my
family
is actually freaked out uh
when we when my sisters and i usually
walk in the afternoon on a weekend and
uh nowadays my my nephews
will text my sister uh and say mom you
have to be careful
be careful that when you're walking that
you have somebody with you don't walk by
yourself my son will say the same thing
mom don't go grocery you just have to
deliver groceries and
don't walk by by yourself uh and my
response to this
is why does have my son or my nephew be
worried about me
just taking a fresh air outside
it is not right
and i think uh as unifying and having
this conversation
is it's a it's a really important thing
uh
at this moment thank you
and attorney general ford yes i know you
have several other questions to get to
and i'll be brief i just want to
i'm opening remarks and say thank you
again to all of
our visitors on screen with me general
tong and i
um i get goosebumps as i say this out
loud because after george floyd happened
uh he had my back and he was one of the
first to reach out from the attorney
general world
to say i stand with you brother what can
we do um
in our own community here the a pi
community stood with us
as we saw protests and marches even
during the midst of covet
um standing up with us as
african-americans uh we're experiencing
yet more trauma and you know i've known
um soon to be general i guess that's
probably why he hasn't updated his uh
title yet because he has to be confirmed
but soon to be general banta
i've known him for years in the working
in the assembly in any
legislature and we've always been able
to talk up to each other and with each
other about these
these important issues uh uh
assemblywoman win
um um you a win and i'm
i'm glad to have representative now i
said ming but i heard tom say
hmong and i want to pronounce your name
correctly because my name is aaron not
aaron
so uh when you when you get a chance
please if you correct me
what is it what is it uh representative
so in chinese it's home and in
english it's mang so you are right
either way okay
well i want to thank you again for being
here and let me say something before i
turn to the mic back and that's
something that grace just did which is
we all have to be united we all have to
stand together
on this uh and while we're talking about
conversations
um and you know look i've had these
conversations before this isn't new to
me
um and i'm not just talking about in the
black community i mean i've had
conversations with my aapf friends
about these types of issues it's not a
new conversation and what i said in the
midst of
uh african-americans standing up again
speaking against the trauma
i said that the time for conversation
should be if not over
certainly toward the end of it and what
we should be doing right now is trying
to find
as i said in the african-american
context and in the political forum
context
actual tangible solutions that are going
to rectify and remedy some of these
issues
and so part of the purpose of this
conversation today is to likewise try to
find things that we can tangibly do
in order to stop the hate against the
api community so again thank you so much
for being here
uh and teresa i'll tune in right back to
you for the next question
thank you um as we're talking about what
to do moving forward
um
and and the impact that it's had on the
community we've seen
phrases like kung flu and the china
virus
um be used to describe kobe 19
and these aren't simply cutesy terms and
instead these are deeply inflammatory
and xenophobic terms
and so my question to you is do you
think that the use of these terms gives
license to openly express hateful
rhetoric
and beyond that does hateful rhetoric
then create a normalization of hateful
conduct
and what do we do about it
attorney general tong
well i think congressman mung was gonna
speak so i
i'll defer to her she was trying to get
to her
raise the hand i think icon
i i can chime in too and you know i just
want to reiterate my
gratitude towards attorney general ford
for convening all of us
here today um even though i'm from
another state i have watched you from
afar
and admired um not only uh
your role uh in nevada but how you've
been able to continuously
strengthen the coalitions of different
communities in nevada and really
appreciate that
to attorney general tong thank you for
being a big brother to so many of us
and always checking in on us i really
appreciate you
and um congratulations to soon to be
attorney general
banta uh our community at large across
the nation
is is so proud of you uh and
look forward to working with you um and
you know
look this hatred and bigotry
towards asian americans is nothing new
in this country
as attorney general tong said our his
our country has a history
of targeting and excluding uh
and punishing asian americans um
due to ignorant fear um
and while these incidents are not new
the former president
has been hammering home the message
for over the past year
um during a time when the virus was new
in this country when people were scared
people were losing loved ones their jobs
their homes
and um just maybe looking for scapegoats
and the former president just fed our
community
right to them um using incendiary
language
day after day week after week one of his
last speeches
as president included the words kung fu
and chinese virus
and so it's it's not a coincidence that
there's been a tremendous rise in these
incidents and
that over 3 800 incidents have been
reported
and we all know each of us have talked
to people many people who've had these
incidents happen to them and just
haven't felt comfortable
reporting them so we know the numbers um
are actually
much higher um and so you know this is
what happens when the leader of our
country with the wide platform
when the republican party uh you know
kevin mccarthy our then uh leader in the
republican party of in congress
use the words um and then when we passed
uh a resolution condemning anti-asian
bigotry
a symbolic resolution that cost no money
and had no teeth just symbolic saying
congress stood against
discrimination against asian americans
164 republicans
voted against it so that's the message
that's being sent
by the republican party um and
you know we are here where we are today
thank you and rochelle nguyen
thank you and thank you um general ford
for putting this together i really do
appreciate being included at this um
amazing table i don't feel uh worthy to
be quite honest but
um you know just to reiterate um
what the congresswoman had said words
matter
that those words matter and they matter
over time
and i really think it's time for us to
speak up for ourselves
when people use like things jokingly
flippantly um just casually like the
casual like
racist like language and rhetoric just
can't be tolerated and i think we also
need to count on our friends and allies
to also stand up and say
that's not right um you know just where
we would want the same stand up when we
hear other
like you know racially charged language
being
you know hurled at our friends and
allies and our family members and so i
think it's very important for us to do
that
because when we don't and it becomes a
normal part of
him we've allowed this language and this
rhetoric to be normalized
and it wasn't just our former president
that did this
although he did not help matters any um
you know this has been going on for
quite some time
and so i think it's time for us to stand
up and say that this is harm
harmful after what happened in georgia i
can't tell you how many like young
asian american women came up to me and
it was really like it was like reliving
like trauma that i don't think that they
had recognized
and addressed um they the
over-sexualization of like asian women
of our asian children um and what kind
of
violent effect that could have um on our
communities as a whole so i think it's
time for us to stand up and stand up for
um you know and have our allies and
neighbors also stand up for us
thank you assemblywoman and uh yuin
it's always great to go after the
awesome
assemblywoman it's it's rare to have two
women in the house so thank you for
it's so hard to follow you but uh it's
so nice that general ford had this
foresight of
putting us together and and everybody
here
is my role model and i want to be like
you when i grow up
um but interestingly enough
talking about growing up the families
and you know i have two young kids right
now everybody
is living in the state of fear um you
know
whether or not you're going to get
covered
is on top of everyone's mind so that's
already the biggest stress in the last
year right
now adding on to it is whether or not
i'm going to be attacked when i walk on
the street
when i do simple things like grocery
shopping when i
go to the bank when i you know walk on
the street to do my exercise
am i going to be attacked and that is
the
really really horrible place
to be in because who would want to live
that way
and the professional perpetual foreigner
stereotypes that all of us
asian has been you know experiencing
living in the u.s
it's that question that inevitable
question where are you really from
right or more hostile go back to where
you came from
um these aren't just the everyday things
that we've been experiencing for many
many years i've been asked that question
oh
you know you speak english really well
you must you know
learn it um every day when you're in
your country
but they don't know that i am a us
citizen and so those are the challenges
that we're experiencing and the
the level of hate just got a lot worse
than last few years
so the model might be myth that we are
experienced the total keep quiet and
stay in your lane
and not be seen as visible because the
asian pacific island community has
always been
perceived as invisible and so that is
one of those um i think
uh adding on to the um you know
deeply inflammatory reference uh and
xenophobia term of kung flu and china
virus
it's just letting people know because
our former you know president
let them know that it's okay to say
those things so that's why everyone
felt like they had a badge of courage
and say you know i'm just gonna say it
so until we can really look at how
we can normalize our interaction and be
able to
have not you know a fear when you when
someone is coming up to you or
approaching you
are they gonna be nice to us or they
gonna attack us and that is really the
biggest fear right now
that facing everyone all asian american
across the united states so i really
encourage our federal
leaders as well as our state leaders to
really look at
um tangible things that we can do
to protect our community by having
strict enforcement against these types
of behavior
and i wanted to recognize congresswoman
may for her sponsor of the uh covet
um as well as anti-hate act that is in
the house of representative right now
but we need to do more we need to do
more to be able to make sure
that our children growing up does not
fear
of being who they are
thank you for that um an attorney
general tom
you're muted a general tongue
sorry it's only been a year right we
should know how to use our unmute
buttons
uh i before i say something i was going
to defer to our almost a.g
colleague rob bonta and
rob did you want to jump in here i i was
going to say something about the
stereotypes too
thank you general tom for inviting me
into the conversation i'll just say
a few brief words um first an honor to
be here
uh um i am an assembly member right now
i do hope to be confirmed i haven't yet
uh if i have the honor of being
the attorney general of california i
look forward to working with general
tang and my
longtime friend uh general ford in
neighboring nevada
um congress member man i've i've admired
and respected your work for a long time
and
really thank you for your leadership
during these really challenging times
for our community
and i appreciate the opportunity to
share this space with all of you i think
this space is i think representative of
what we need more of
we have folks from all over this country
coming together uh
in unity showing solidarity allyship
support
common cause to denounce and condemn
what we all know is wrong what we all
know is not the society that we
are and that we want to be and
uh we also know that that words matter
um
you know uh it's it's it needs to be
said again that the
former president used the biggest
megaphone in the world
to push out regularly and consistently
and dangerously uh words of xenophobia
and cruelty
and and hate and racism and it did give
people permission it did give people
license
to act uh on their worst instincts and
to hurt others
and and we're seeing that now um so it's
important
leaders use our bully pulpit uh to to
speak words of unity
and healing and and support and love for
our different communities
um the api community is under attack
right now uh
but it's not the only time a community
has been targeted
and and attacked and it's been the
african-american community the
jewish-american community
latino community lgbtq community and
it's important that we all stand
together
and speak with one voice unify and and
condemn and
and to general ford's comments and and
some of the other comments to take
action
um what that action is can can vary we
probably have a healthy debate about the
best ways to
you know prevent hate crimes uh support
victims
so they can heal uplift and invest in
our communities
um but i'd really appreciate the the
federal hate crimes bill congressman
it's a very thoughtful contribution
and solution at a time when it's most
needed so i'm just very appreciative for
the opportunity to be here in the space
with all of you thank you for inviting
me general ford
um i'm honored uh to be in the presence
of such incredible leaders and and to
work with you
thank you i know particularly win has to
go but i won't give her the last word
before she leaves and then
general tong i'll turn back to you
please thank you so much i i'm sorry
for those of you that are for those of
you that are not from nevada
um we only meet every other year for 120
days and so we
have some first committee passages dates
coming up right around the corner so
unfortunately i do have to run and do
some state business here
um the people's business really um but
before i left i did want to see
um say thank grace and all of her
members um i see her there
i think we can't like
focus enough on you know the aapi
community that our frontline workers in
these hospitals the nurses the nursing
staff
that are in there fighting this like
horrible like
global health pandemic and then now also
having to deal with
the visceral hate and violence that is
out there on the streets so
um i appreciate all the work that her
and her members are doing and
um thank you guys for including me in
this and have a wonderful night
thank you so much
um well congresswoman there's been a
number of people that have touched on it
and so i think this would be a good time
uh you recently proposed the code 19
hate crimes act
can you give us an overview of what that
would accomplish if passed
sure thank you this is legislation that
i
and senator mazie hirono from hawaii
introduced it really would
just try to streamline some of the
processes under which the department of
justice
analyzes and collects data on hate
crimes
right now there's sort of a state by
state approach
um there it's not unified or centralized
at all
uh it would assign a point person at the
department of justice uh to be able to
review
these uh incidents uh it would also
provide
resources and guidance to our local
community and law enforcement to help
with training on how to assess and
investigate
uh these hate incidents as as well and
also
a component is public education
resources to talk to the community so
it makes it easier for victims to
report these
these types of incidents um it and and
i'm thankful to
president biden for supporting
the legislation as you may know he
announced the white house announced a
few initiatives
today uh through the administration that
would also
provide a lot of support uh and
resources
uh in in relation to uh hate crimes
against asian americans as well
great thank you and um i want to open
this question up first to attorney
general ford
um there are reports that anti-asian
bias incidents have been on the rise on
a national level
um but as been touched on already today
those are only the reports that have
been made to law enforcement
um and so can you give us an overview on
how people should report racially
motivated incidents
or hate crimes and then a larger
question for the panel
is what resources are there for people
who
are victims of these racially motivated
incidences
absolutely teresa that's that's a great
question and
um you know the the point is we've only
had 3 800 some art reports but we know
more out there
and the key is again talking about
actions that we can take to help
push back on aep i hate one of those
actions is to report it
you have to speak up we have to have
people who are going to reach out to law
enforcement and let them know
that these things are taking place it's
very difficult for law enforcement to
take action against someone
who harmed you if we don't know about it
and to be sure it takes a lot of courage
to come forward and to report a crime
especially something as traumatic and as
degrading as a hate crime
or being harassed simply because of the
color of your skin and trust me
i know what i'm talking about here and i
can stand with you on these issues
um and it doesn't seem fair where you
have to have the burden of reporting the
crime
but we need you to and the first line of
defense for that the first line of uh
defense and the last line of defense
frankly is local law enforcement
uh here in nevada at least we need you
to reach out to local law enforcement
whether
you're in the city of henderson for
example call the henderson pd
uh call metro call north las vegas pd
you're watching this in elko if you're
watching this
in reno call local pd so that they can
know that these things are happening
and it's also something um that i should
share is that it's also against the law
to discriminate
against someone because of the race of
national origin at work
in housing in the places open to the
public like restaurants and casinos
and retail stores and schools and
illegal discrimination also includes
using yes
ethnic slurs against someone so if
you've been discriminated against or
harassed at your job
or by your landlord especially during
these times or by
a public business you should file a
complaint here in nevada with the nevada
equal rights commission
so those are two things that you can do
at the outset to
help us start to remedy these issues
speak up
and report to local authorities or to
the human rights commission
to the equal rights commission that we
have here in nevada
uh one of the questions that we actually
just got in the in the chat box that i
think is relevant is
um a question of how do you talk about
this with your kids
um either for members of the aapi
community how do you prepare your kids
for this
and for those that want to be allies how
do you talk to your kids
about racial discrimination
a.j tong thank you teresa
i think it's really important that
kids understand and all people
understand that these stereotypes aren't
funny
and they're very hurtful and damaging
and potentially dangerous
and and it reminds me a little bit of
when jeremy lin first burst on the scene
and and there was a lot of ridicule of
jeremy lin
and making fun of his name and the fact
that he was asian the great yellow hope
and hong kong foue and i remember a lot
of that
and there was some discussion about why
is it okay to make fun of jeremy lin
right when it clearly wouldn't be okay
to make fun of other athletes of color
in the same way and i think we missed
the opportunity then
to have that conversation but now
um i think we see how really damaging
these stereotypes are right the
stereotypes that asian americans and
pacific islanders suffer from
we all know that we're quiet that we're
meek
that we don't rock the boat right even
asian americans buy into this nonsense
and and what those what those
stereotypes signal is that we are weak
and you can prey on us and it empowers
people and emboldens people
and then talk about asian american women
in particular
they're objectified through a racist
lens they're seen as exotic
submissive hyper-sexualized
and and what messages does that send to
a guy
in atlanta georgia right who's capable
of murdering eight people including six
asian american women
that guy let's just be honest that guy
didn't take on
six men six foot four 275 pounds each
right he went after asian-american women
and it's because
these stereotypes these messages are
cumulative
right and they make people unsafe
they're dangerous
and that's why i think with my kids i've
got to educate them
you can't just let it go right you can't
just let the
name calling and the mocking go you
can't just laugh it off
you've got to push back because it's
cumulative
and it builds and particularly my two
asian and
american young women you know that i'm
trying to raise
it makes them unsafe and it puts them at
risk
and and that's why it's so important to
push back on these stereotypes
thank you and grace burger mctell
well i think um i remember when my son
was
seven eight years old and um
we've talked about because he was first
time
going to be in the school bus and he
would come home and say
kids are teasing him and i always talk
to him and say do not tolerate any
racial jokes
because it is not right to just accept
it
so any racial justice he was he's been
called chopsticks
kings you know slanted eyes and all of
that and i said no you should not
tolerate it and i think we need to teach
our children that
so whenever you hear any jokes or for
especially for young young children
because they think it's funny they think
it's okay no it's not okay
so you you gotta tell your parents you
gotta tell your teacher
so when my son said that that they hear
his
friends or his uh the children in the
bus was calling him chopsticks
you know i brought the chopsticks i went
into the uh
uh the bus station and i said to and i
said to
the the because he was he was
three grades older than my son i said do
you know the difference between my son
and chopsticks
so this is a chopstick and this is a
so we gotta talk to children to speak
out tell your parents
and for the child for our young adults
like my son 23 years old
that when he hears anybody making jokes
about any racial jokes
stop it you gotta step up and say it's
not funny
and it's not appropriate because the
jokes becomes reality for folks and
becomes a stereotype
and that's when you know we and like uh
general trump says we have this notion
of
asians are you know keep quiet keep your
head down
don't rock the boat don't do anything
but
that should not be well i for once not
but i think everybody should be able to
say and speak up
uh when they see something is wrong
thank you and uh congresswoman
it's it's hard i feel like i want
a guidebook on you know the
best 20 responses to use when someone
hurls a racial slur at you right
um and i think
talking to your kids kind of preparing
them
um mentally letting them understand that
it is important
to speak up and what grace said was
incredibly true in that
for so many of us including myself
especially when i was younger and when
it was happening the first few times
you know i just i kept quiet about it if
i was with my parents
they didn't speak english they didn't
know that someone was making fun of me
or fun of us um so for most of my
childhood i just let it go you know
they weren't really incidents that put
me in any real
physical harm's way um but
it's true like with all the incidents in
the past few weeks happening to the
elderly and then the tragedies
in atlanta um we have heard from so many
people
um talking about these incidents that
have happened throughout their lifetime
um and you know i i want to say to
people right now who
you know there's so many people who ask
how they can help and how
they can be allies this is one of the
things that
we can do is to provide the space and to
have these conversations with people
because people don't necessarily
understand it's always been
politically acceptable and socially
acceptable to kind of taunt
asian americans and so just speaking up
oftentimes is probably what people don't
expect
at all um but also encouraging our
children to understand that this
applies to every community my kids are
in middle school
i took them to some of the black lives
matters protests
that were happening in new york last
year
here and and these are some of their
first protests but i wanted them to be
there to listen to the words and to the
experience
of other people in our community
who may not look like them but who also
suffer through
painful experiences in their lives and
again i don't have the exact words and
right answers to say
but it's important for me as a parent to
try to create those
opportunities where we can have those
conversations
thank you and attorney general ford you
know uh congresswoman mung just hit the
nail on the head
she talks about what allies can do i
can't tell you how many times i got that
question
what can we do as allies in the
aftermath of george floyd and to be
honest with you
i was doing my own trauma at the time
and didn't have a good answer i didn't
know what to tell them
um but i thought about it and i'm so
glad that
congresswoman has given you some
tangible things right in the midst of
the trauma that's going on right now
because what happens is this uh and
we've seen it happen over
since george floyd for example uh people
get complacent
the fervor dies down and people get
quiet and then
um as the congresswoman says when it
comes time to hit the green button
for example as a congress person or as a
legislator
they don't they hit the red button they
they hit the red button they text you
and say
you know i'm with you i stand with you
but when it comes to actually make a
decision
to help effectuate real positive change
on the issue they stand back
so as an ally don't be that person be
there when the fervor dies down
speak up right now um the talk that i
have with my kids
everybody knows about it it's all over
the news you've heard about the talk
of a black man to black boys you've
heard about that but part of the
conversation i have with my kids
is the same one you've heard them say on
this screen right here which is you do
not tolerate intolerance
there is no room for tolerating
intolerance
when you hear it you speak up you defend
yourself but you defend others as well
and how you have to understand that you
have a role in trying to eradicate
this utter nonsense that's existed for
way too long
and and i want to move folks and i'll be
quiet after this from a position of
ignorance
and i don't mean that in a pejorative
sense i mean literally ignorance they
don't know
some people don't know that they've made
something that's offensive so move them
from ignorance
to intentionality what do i mean by that
i mean that means that when they make an
ignorant statement
you correct them you teach them and that
way if they do it again
you know it wasn't ignorance it was
intentional and then you can categorize
them as you
as you desire but as an ally you have to
speak up
during this time but beyond this time
when the fervor dies down
you continue to speak up and speak out
and when the time hits it
comes right for you to be able to take
some affirmative steps and actions
you do that as well
thank you and mr banta well yeah thank
you for this
um uh really incredible discussion and
the very thoughtful
uh insight here on the issue of
stereotypes the thing about stereotypes
that can be so damaging is
um that it dehumanizes uh
people and lessens their value and
um reduces them to something less than
human if we can see our
our common humanity if we can humanize
all people and get past the
the labels and the stereotypes and i
think um that's a way to talk to our to
our young people and
and and sometimes it means um taking a
stroll through
through history and asian american
history and talking about some things
that are painful
the immigrants who were excluded
communities that were rounded up and
interned
uh communities that were prevented from
owning property
or entering certain public
accommodations people who were killed
vincent chin the shootings in atlanta
and and then saying you know what
you know those are human beings how do
you think their family felt how do you
think
uh uh what you know what was that
experience for their communities
and but also talk about hope and
inspiration and optimism the incredible
api leaders that have led the incidents
that have changed our world
i was born in the philippines and came
here as a two-month-old and my hero is
my mother
who fought against um martial law and
human rights abuses at ferdinand marcos
until
democracy was restored in 1986 um
she was part of the united farm workers
of america movement uh helped fight for
greater justice
and and that that that those stories of
power and agency
and change-making um i think can inspire
our young people to believe
that they can help create a world uh
that is not where we need to be yet um
so acknowledging and absorbing that that
pain
and that reality of where we are but but
seeing where we need to go
and inspiring them to help take us there
because they can
thank you and and since you brought it
up and i know aj tong mentioned it as
well
um if we're looking at the history of
treatment in the us of asian communities
starting with the youth exclusion act of
1882 in the japanese and tournament
camps during world war
ii um i mean they say that those that
don't learn from history are doomed to
repeat it
and so what do we need to learn from the
history of the treatment of asians in
america
mr bond i'll start with you since
well i i think the asian american
history is so important
um you know telling our stories our
beautifully diverse stories ethnic
studies is really important
um the history has not um captured the
full
um dimensions of all of our experiences
here in
in this country and in you know
california the most diverse state in the
nation
and uplifting those stories i was a
history major in college
i looked in history books as a young boy
as a high school student as a college
student for the stories of me
and my family of the filipino-american
experience and i could never find it
and so what i spent time writing about
as a history major in college is
is giving voice to silences in history
filling gaps where stories weren't told
where great leaders led and events
happened
but they weren't being told and um i
thought that was important it was a way
to honor
our our our elders our manongs and
manon's in the filipino-american
community
to inspire our young people growing up
who feel invisible
and unimportant because they don't see
themselves in the history books
shaping uh our country and our state as
although it's true and so it's important
to tell those to tell those stories
and and to share our diverse experiences
and part of it is
telling the painful ones uh because it's
important to know what
people are capable of doing it's not
imagined it's not intellectual
it's true it's what we did to one
another so human beings are capable of
some awful ugly things
um but knowing about them and knowing uh
that
uh you know they should be condemned and
denounced and we should move forward
in uh with more unity and love for one
another i think is really important too
thank you
and uh congresswoman well i think that
this
goes to the very issue of invisibility
that has
been mentioned throughout tonight um we
are practically invisible from
our school textbooks to the budget books
of our government in fact a study just
came out today where
philanthropic organizations i think
asian american organizations
received i think about point twenty
percent
not even one percent of all the money
charitable money that is given out to
various communities
in new york city asian americans
represent 15
of the population and we get about 1
percent
of the city budget that goes towards our
communities um
and so you know we we need to be
teaching our history
um i'm working on legislation with the
congressional black
caucus and hispanic caucus and our
native american
uh colleagues to be able to
expand our curriculum you know growing
up i didn't learn much about the chinese
building the railroad
japanese americans being incarcerated
even slaves building the us capital
the very place where i go to work every
single day
so we are pretty much erased from our
textbooks and if we really want to
address the long-term solutions of
breaking down
you know biases and stereotypes it has
to start
uh with our kids
thank you and you we win thank you
and just want to echo the congresswoman
on that invisibility piece from the
educational standpoint
you know not only um going from the top
level but just at the everyday level of
education
that you know the nonprofit that i work
for in community development council as
well as one api in nevada
we're here to educate you know with
there's um 13
uh of api in nevada and and we're about
300 000 here in las vegas and
there are just so much happening but no
one talks about us right we're not
represented
in any conversation whether it's at the
corporate table
um whether it's at you know uh
government local
state uh regional level i mean it's 2021
and we still have you know i mean all of
you on this call are the first of
something
it's 2021 why is there i mean it's just
mind-blowing that we're still the first
of something right
um there should be more opportunity
created
for uh for us at the table and we should
grab it and we should really be a part
of conversation you know talking about
invisible in history right now we're
invisible in the process
and and thank you to you know a.g ford
for
you to always be inclusive and and you
were my state senator
for many years and and i know that you
always do a great job of reaching out to
us
but there needs to be many more like you
because we just can't
um have conversation at the table or
we're not there i mean
there's there used to be a joke hey you
know what if you're not
um at the table you're on the menu right
and i know
none of you uh want to be on the menu
so the challenge for us is that we need
to consistently
um fight for a spot at the table
and that shouldn't be the case anymore
where conversation
in in our country should be inclusive
and it's not just check the box
conversation
we have to be actionable and we have to
really
involve all the generations together and
be able to come up
with ways to to make sure that
we just look beyond just the the race
conversation we just need to look at
individual
uh and the expression of being who we
are
and celebrate for our uniqueness and our
differences as well as our contribution
to the country
and so we want to be able to do that in
a more organic way
these hate crimes um this incident is
just
really um a a reminder for us that
there's still a lot more work to do you
know the work here
that we do the work here that that seiu
is doing
you know across the country and over the
world you know and all the work that all
the elected leaders do is so important
but guess what we only do it when
something happens and that shouldn't be
the case
it should be 24 7 year round and we need
to come together
and make sure that we're not only
visible when some bad happens
your comment about having a seat at the
table um it brings to mind a year ago
andrew yang did an op-ed in the
washington post and he made the argument
that
asian americans actually have the burden
it's it's their onus to step up and
demonstrate their own american-ness
that that's how you'll dis-incentivize
people from targeting asians
it's the idea that if you work hard to
assimilate you wear your red white and
blue and you partake in volunteering in
the community
that you can show though around you that
you're also an american
and by doing that you'll decrease
xenophobia
do you think that's an effective
strategy or
what would you like to see
well i'll address it real quick and i
know other folks have
jamming on is that you know going back
to that professional foreign issue
i mean there is nothing that any one of
us should do to make us more american
you know in view of others nor is it
something that individuals should strive
to do
assuming that assimilation is key to
achieving the american as
places a very heavy burden of addressing
the anti-asian violence on
asian pacific under american this is not
an effective strategy
and it does not change predators
prejudice
prejudices about asian and the
mainstream
so we need to continue to to look at you
know
um ways to really
think about how um we can be feel
american by just being simply who we are
and celebrate
our differences rather than trying to
assimilate
into one
thank you congresswoman
so i know there's been a lot of
discussion on andrew yang's op-ed
um and i will say that while the most
effective strategies
the strategies are you know educating
the public
about our history which we've talked
about um
calling on the role of media to
highlight the contributions of our asian
american
community to this country
i will say that for part of my life
i probably fought a little bit in
similar terms of
what andrew was saying because i felt
that i was on the defense
um on what on how my story and my
experience needed to fit into what
people thought of
as to be american enough and now i
understand that we can be on the offense
our history
it might look different than what you
know what people think
it might sound funny it might you know
the foods might look funny but
this is a part of our history and and
our history
our experiences are just as american as
anyone else and i will tell you
some of the people who really solidified
that feeling and those
teaching in me are the six asian
american women who died in atlanta
because for too long um many of us have
been
maybe embarrassed about our history
or thinking you know that we we were
we've been made to
feel like uh foreigners and outsiders
uh in our very own country but those
women and i told this
to their children um when i met them in
atlanta over the weekend
when we visited them that their moms
um you know they their legacy to this
country
is that they have empowered so many
asian americans
especially asian american women to own
up
and to be proud be confident um
in the history and the contributions and
the sacrifices
that they've made for their family and
that their story is just as american as
anyone else
thank you and uh grace regardmental
um i always tell my son to be yourself
and be proud is that not what everybody
wants right so i but i but i think it is
really
um about intentional uh making uh
educating our community our family and
intentionally doing that
i think be proud of the history so i
think the contributions
of the asians have made to america it's
not
talked about like everybody says in the
panel but
from you know from the chinese building
the railroads to the filipino monongs
and the prime workers
to now help our workers the day in day
out
have helped and fought kovit 19 and some
of them sacrificed the ultimate
sacrifice that they lost their lives
right i think those are the things that
we need to be proud of and
we need to talk about what are the
contributions that we made
in this country and i think that is
something that we
have to talk about on the dining table
talk about our children and be proud of
that uh
because i think you know i want to
believe that we live in a country that
promotes and champions our individuality
our culture our uniqueness and recognize
our diversity
rather than notion of assimilation we
should be loud and proud of ourselves
we should not be invisible we should not
we should not be
shy we should not put your head down
speak up
and be proud thank you
and attorney general tong
thank you i know we're running short on
time um andrew was a year behind me in
college
um he he did incredible things in that
campaign but like
i could not disagree more with that
sentiment and you know
i don't have to prove anything to
anybody uh i'm as
you know my my american
identity and the fact of my parents
american citizenship
and my citizenship were earned through
their sacrifice
and their perseverance and
um the the struggle of their immigration
in this country and how they work 15
hours a day seven days
a week for me in our chinese restaurant
they earn that
and um to paraphrase i think a
korean-american woman journalist at cnn
who was
attacked in an airport she said i'm as
american as korean barbecue
well then i'm as american as port fried
rice and
i think one of the challenges though is
we don't tell our stories enough and and
let me say what happens when we don't
tell our stories enough
our allies don't know that they're
allies
and and let me give an experience when
the president declare
war on america's immigrants president
trump not this president president trump
when he declared america's immigrants
everybody thought he was talking about
people at the southern border he was
talking about
hispanics and people from latin america
and mexico
and he said that he wanted to
denaturalize american citizens
immigrants who came here and earned
their citizenship
it occurred to me well shoot he's
talking about my parents
and then he went he went on and this is
a common attack
he attacked anchor babies you know the
native
born american-born children of immigrant
parents and then it occurred to me
he's talking about me i'm an anchor baby
i'm a proud anchor baby and
and i think our community grace i think
you hit it on the head
we're way past changing our names and
anglicizing them we're way past
trying to not have our children speak
our native tongue or hide the fact of
who we are i mean look at me
they can tell you know
you're not gonna hide it and so let's
embrace that and then when you tell
those stories
you know about immigration for example
and our immigration experience
guess what other immigrant communities
say holy smokes
we have the same experience and that's
what creates
true alliances right and brings true
allies to the table
thank you for that and aj ford i know
we're probably getting close to the time
if not past it and i know we have to
wrap it up
i just want to thank everybody again and
and say um
listen education i've said this before
but it's always been used to
indoctrinate
education has always been used to
indoctrinate uh
by what they include in the books and
what they exclude in the books i'm born
and raised in the south
i'm a black man in the south and we know
the history of black people in the south
uh and while i uh unlike um
soon to be general banta could see some
depictions of myself in the history
books
those depictions were purposefully
picked to describe who i was what i was
about and what i was supposed to do when
i grew up
um i have to be honest with you the
first time i learned about the chinese
exclusion act
was in law school and i think as we say
those
that that act out loud right now we're
presuming something and that is that
people who are watching us
know what that even is um just so you
all know
we we our country passed the law said
chinese folks can't come to our borders
just stop them point blank no no more
we're done with them
we got enough over here that they can do
the railroads and can do x y and z
so we excluded them that's what's called
the chinese exclusion act
and the first time i learned about that
was not in the history book in dallas
texas
it was not even in college at texas a m
or george washington university or at
the ohio state university until i got to
a law school class at the ohio state
they had talked to me about this thing
and you know what you know mr tong you
know what it was about
it was me it was me learning that
congress had the right to exclude
whoever they wanted to
that was the concept i was being taught
when i learned about the child
it looks like a.g ford is having a
little bit of an internet connection
problem
but since we are at time i would love to
hear
final thoughts from everyone um where do
we
where do we go from here what do we do
next um so let's start with you grace
regardmental
thank you um i think we need to continue
to drive and lead on this conversation
uh like a.g ford says this conversation
have
been going on but i think it's uh it has
you know we got to continue it we got to
continue to educate
uh our men even the members of our
family that sometimes
yep
so i think the education that that our
family
within the dining table and to our
friends so we gotta extend it
we we do it uh like i said earlier seiu
has the anti-israel anti-racist
organizations and it's and because we
believe that
it's not enough that you're not racist
you have to be anti-racist
and we have to educate our our family
our children
about being anti-racist i think you know
it education leads to change and we have
to change
it impacts our policies in law there is
still much to do
in educating our friends our communities
our policy makers
and our even our law enforcement
agencies but
we must they must hear our issues they
must understand our issue
so that in turn we are working in
partnership to build better future
and safe and for our api community and i
think
it's important that this this
collaboration with different community
organization happens not only with the
api community but also our lawmakers and
again
i i am humbled to be here and i thank
our
lawmakers for um you know
intentionally focusing on on the api
issue
so thank you so much and thank you so
much grace
uh yuin thank you again
um for having me on this panel i think
you know at the end of the day um just
reiterating a few things i said earlier
is that we just need to continue to make
space for each other
and learn more about each other um and
and realize that there's so much
diversity
uh within all of our communities and
frankly
with the asian community itself i mean
according to the last census and
we can't wait to see that number um
later this year on the recent census
but just right here in clark county
nevada alone we have 28 different
cultures and languages
within the asian pacific islander
community alone right 28
imagine trying to get all of that
together and really
um celebrate right we are not a monolith
we we not one check box and and you're
done right
there's just so many different cultures
within this
um diverse community so we need to do
more to educate
ourselves and educate those around us
and and education
i believe is the only way we can we can
overcome these
um challenges we have
access issue language barrier healthcare
access
issue uh food insecurity you know
immigrations
uh a variety of inequality uh through
our economic lens
and also attacking on discrimination on
top of it so
i i urge um you know all of our leaders
federal
or state or even local leaders to
continue
to collaborate and work with us and
support
our ability to move our community
forward and make sure that there's
always a space for us at the table
thank you so much uh mr banta
sorry slow to unmute i'm sorry we lost
uh general ford there for technical
difficulties he was killing it and i was
enjoying it so
uh uh uh uh maybe there's a secret feat
i can get later to get the full
uh power of it all um well i i'm just
very honored to be invited into this
into the space
just honored to be with so many powerful
leaders it's important that we continue
to speak out
be loud condemn denounce uh show
solidarity
allyship unity fight side by side with
one another but then uh
i think to general ford's earlier
comments turn
that pain that anger that frustration
into action that is durable
and to systems change um into policy
tools that will help us reduce hate
violence and bring us closer together
and i think education cannot be um
uh under emphasized uh or undervalued
because it's so important that we
continue to tell our audience and that
we learn more about one another we'll
see the beauty and the value in the
humanity and
everyone's stories and experiences and
value as if we do that
thank you again for having me thank you
um and attorney general tong
thank you and thank you general ford for
convening us tonight
and thank you all for being part of this
the only thing i would say
is while i disagree with um andrew that
we have to prove that we're american
um i think we have to do a better job of
proving to
each other the value in in joining
together
and being strong and cohesive as a
community
i think too many
for too long we talk about coming
together right
on a sort of pan-asian basis
and and and we talk about our allies
outside the asian-american community
well we got a
fixed ally ship in our own community and
and people got to get out of their own
way and stop
saying well you know i'm a chinese
american i'm a korean american and
you know i'm not the same space as a
filipino american or a
south asian american not true right
we're all in the same
place and um
and and we have the same challenges and
we just got to get over the egos and the
beefing
and like that person didn't talk to me
right 15 years ago and just
come together really because can't do it
by ourselves
thank you for that and congresswoman
bang i agree with everyone's comments
look never in my life have i seen such a
widespread showing of support
from people who don't look like me for
our community
we have a very rare opportunity we might
never have this opportunity again
we have limited time um attorney general
ford is right
sometimes their fervor dies down and the
willingness to act
uh goes away and we have to raise
awareness and like attorney general tom
said
not just within allies right like we can
talk about
allyship and i can i can talk about how
the black and latino caucus
colleagues stood with the asian caucus
colleagues from day one
of all this that was going on but it's
not just about addressing racism
that's aimed at our communities but also
addressing racism that may exist within
our own communities
um and this is the time right now to
have these uncomfortable but necessary
conversations
it might just be up to you and me
there's no guidebook
there's no googling how to talk to
people
um about these issues i had a
conversation and i've been trying to
have conversations with
for example some of my own leaders in my
own area
and i said to you know in an asian
ethnic newspaper
i said whenever you uh describe um
when when a perpetrator of a hate
incident is white
you don't talk about his race but when
when the person is black you go
in depth to describe what he looks like
um these are necessary and really tough
conversations that
that we have to have within our within
our own communities
um i i heard a local activist say a few
weeks ago that
the answer to racism is not more racism
it's solidarity
um and we literally have to guide our
communities right now
um to help them see that and and feel
that and to practice that
it's not easy it doesn't come natural
for for everyone
um it might come natural for the few of
us who are gathered here today
but we have we have to spread that we
have to be intentional about it
thank you for that and um attorney
general four the last word is yours
well i appreciate it apparently i froze
it's probably a good thing because i was
starting to get hype and i might never
anyway i needed to uh i need to take a
breather um
i'll just close by by mentioning a book
that i referenced because look to be
sure
i'm a black man talking about stop aap i
hate
um and it's not an attempt to co-opt the
conversation uh it's
purposeful for me to show that we have
commonality
that that the issues that i've
experienced over the course of my life
are comparable to what you've
experienced of course yours and that's
generation upon generation
and the book i was going to talk about
before i got cut off was the
miseducation of the negro it's a book
written
by carter g woodson and in the book he
talks about
the miseducation of the negro and the
premise that i'm going to paraphrase
that if you control the way a person
thinks you don't have to worry about the
way they'll act
because they will conform to how you've
trained them to think
see i've been in the business of mind
control with my kids for 27 years now
because i want to know i want to know i
want to control how they act
and this book talks about it in the
black context that if you make a person
think that he's shiftless lazy good for
nothing
his woman is no good you're not a good
father you're not a good man
then that's how that person is going to
act and for generations that happened
and so we had to un recognize the
mis-education
in order to re-educate so that my sons
know that they can be whoever they want
to be
they're not shifters in fact they're the
brilliant the geniuses they can do
and i offer this in the context of this
conversation because we have to
re-educate the public about
the aapi experience here as well this
modern minority concept that we've heard
people talk about right now
uh this this ignorance that we have
about the chinese exclusion act unless
you go to law school
these are types of things that we are
responsible for doing and as an ally i'm
committed to standing next to you
with you um and you know right right on
top of you
i shouldn't say it that way right next
to you you get the point i'm just trying
to be on and on with you
to get this done so thank you so much
for taking time out of your evening
schedules on the east coast and on your
afternoon schedules here on the west
coast to have this conversation
more than that we've given people some
concrete ideas of things they can do
you know um when file a complaint either
with your police officers
or with the equal rights commission here
in our state and speak out as an ally
when you see these things are happening
uh and so again thank you so much for
having us out here teresa thank you so
much for moderating this it was
fantastic
uh and i look forward to continuing to
work with everybody else to stop
api